[Applaus]
in der welt der politik stellt die
europäische union in etwa dass da was
microsoft windows für die welt der
betriebssysteme ist je länger es
installiert ist desto weiter blickt es
sich auf bild alles zu und läuft immer
lahme und bleibe
und je weiter das system verstopft desto
öfter kommt es zu hässlichen abstürzen
aber seien wir ehrlich die anderen
alternativ haben auch ihre macken können
damit so manchen in den wahnsinn treiben
und letztendlich kommen sie verdammt
teuer
[Musik]
einige politische analysten behaupten
gar der exit sei der anfang vom ende der
europäischen union wieder einmal sind
die dinge jedoch etwas komplexer denn
eigentlich sind nicht alle fans der eu
auf einer linie
viele von ihnen teilen nicht einmal die
gleiche meinung darüber was denn die eu
an sich eigentlich sein sollte zb steht
makro für eine fiskalunion mit gleichen
steuern in jedem land angela merkel und
jean claude juncker sind daran alles
andere als interessiert schließlich
kommt junker aus dem steuerparadies
luxemburg
andererseits forderte der ehemalige
belgische premierminister key
verhofstadt europa solle genau wie die
usa ein bundesstaat werden
aber sind damit wirklich alle
einverstanden nun die antwort die uns
nur wenig überrascht lautet nein
eigentlich ist das einzige worüber sich
alle diese politiker einig sind die
tatsache dass die ihn an sich irgendwie
doch eine gute sache ist aber was ist
die eu eigentlich und was soll aus ihr
irgendwann werden worauf läuft das ganze
eigentlich hinaus eine konföderation
also ein staatenbund oder eher so etwas
wie eine eidgenossenschaft wie ein
bundesstaat wie sehen die verschiedenen
modelle die auf den verhandlungstisch
liegen denn nun konkret aus nun heute
werden wir euch auf alle diese fragen
antworten liefern
[Musik]
was wäre wenn margaret thatcher recht
gehabt hätte margaret thatcher ist so
was mit elvis presley der eu-skeptiker
seit jahrzehnten inspiriert jede frau
welche die ganzen 80er jahre über als
premierministerin regentin über
großbritannien war
viele jener kräfte die das europäische
vereinigung project am liebsten beenden
wollen
aber wie ihr wisst sind die dinge nur
selten so simpel wie sie oberflächlich
scheinen nun es stimmt dass margaret
thatcher eine große kritikerin der
politischen integration europas war
damals gab es die eu noch nicht
zumindest die sie noch nicht so es gab
eine europäische gemeinschaft von
ländern die in erster linie auf
gemeinsamen handel und wirtschaftliche
integration ausgelegt war damals in den
80er jahren haben sich die verschiedenen
europäischen regierungen und schlossen
diese integration zu vertiefen
[Applaus]
sie begann über eine gemeinsame währung
und neue gemeinschaftsinstrument
all dies kumulierte 1992 mit der
unterzeichnung des maastricht-vertrags
aber was genau dachte margaret thatcher
drüber wenn wir alle stereotypen über
bord und einen blick in ihre memoiren
werfen finden wir zitate wie dieses
[Applaus]
großbritannien träumt nicht von einer
gemütlichen isolierten existenz am rande
der europäischen gemeinschaft unser
schicksal liegt in europa als teil der
gemeinschaft
das sind schöne worte aber er war nicht
unbedingt einer meinung mit ihren
europäischen kollegen denn ihr schwebte
ein anderes modell vor
anders als diejenigen die von den
vereinigten staaten von europa mit
brüssel als hauptstadt träumten
sicherlich wollen wir ein einiges europa
mit einem stärkeren sinn für gemeinsame
ziele aber dies muss in einer art und
weise geschehen die die
unterschiedlichen traditionen als auch
parlamentarische beschlüsse und das
gefühl des nationalen stolz zu seinem
eigenen land war wofür wir weitermachen
müssen wir nun wirklich klären was ist
der unterschied zwischen einem
bundesstaat auf englisch federation und
einem staatenbund confederation ein
beispiel für ein bundesstaat wären die
vereinigten staaten von amerika texas
und kalifornien haben ihre eigenen
parlamente ihre eigene regierung und
ihre eigenen gesetze
heute zum beispiel ist marihuana in
kalifornien egal während es in texas
verboten ist wenn jedoch der
bundeskongress in washington dc ein
gesetz verabschieden würde welches
cannabis in den ganzen usa legalisiert
würde dadurch jedes gesetz eines
einzelnen bundesstaates das diesem
bundesgesetz widerspricht automatisch
ungültig
in einem staatenbund haben die
mitgliedsstaaten viel mehr autonomie
heute gibt es auf der welt offiziell
keinen einzigen staatenbund nicht einmal
die schweiz natürlich genießen die
verschiedenen kantone in der schweiz
viel autonomie und sogar
unterschiedliche steuersätze aber das
bedeutet nicht dass sie ein staatenbund
ist wenn beispielsweise das parlament in
bern ein gesetz verabschieden würde das
marihuana legalisiert müssten dies die
einzelnen kantone akzeptieren und
umsetzen wäre die schweiz ein echter
staatenbund müsste jedes kantons
parlament einzeln über die legalisierung
von cannabis abstimmen ungeachtet dessen
was viele leute glauben ist die schweiz
daher eindeutig ein bundesstaat
und jetzt fragt ihr euch sicherlich was
ist denn nun eigentlich die eu-staaten
bund oder bundesstaat es gibt natürlich
viele leute die das föderale also
bundesstaatliche modell für die eu
wollen in den letzten fünf jahren war
der präsident der europäischen liberalen
guy verhofstadt der vorkämpfer dieser
idee
er trägt wie vor wir müssen europa so
umformen dass wir einen echten
bundesstaat daraus machen der fähig ist
zu handeln nicht nur im wirtschaftlichen
bereich sondern auch in dem eine
verteidigungsgemeinschaft errichtet wird
in dem eine europäische
ermittlungsbehörde geschaffen hat indem
ein echter europäischer grenz und
küstenschutz geschaffen wird um alle
äußeren grenzen der eu zu schützen
was heute kaum der fall ist aber kehren
wir mal zu den fakten zurück
heute haben obwohl es nicht danach
aussieht nationale regierungen in der eu
viel autonomie die mehrwertsteuer zum
beispiel die wichtigste steuer in europa
ist in jedem land anders geregelt in
spanien zahlt der 21 prozent aber in
ungarn 27 und in deutschland sind es nur
zehn prozent
dies ist
die usa jedoch ehrlich auch dort hat
jeder bundesstaat seine eigene
mehrwertsteuersätze weil die zentrale
regierung dies zulässt und darin liegt
der große unterschied
[Applaus]
jede von der eu erlassene richtlinie
muss in jedem einzelnen mitgliedstaat dh
vom dortigen parlament in nationales
recht umgesetzt werden
erst dann entfaltet sie reale
gesetzeskraft in diesem land und das
kann dauern und gleichzeitig zu einer
totalen verbesserung des eigentlichen
zwecks führen
vor einigen jahren hat brüssel
beispielsweise eine richtlinie zum
rauchverbot in gaststätten erlassen
danach musste jedes mitgliedsland über
sein eigenes rauchverbots gesetz
abstimmen und viele haben es nur sehr
zögerlich oder unvollständig umgesetzt
während irland schon sehr früh totale
rauchverbot erließ und durchsetzte
konnte man in den cafés von prag noch
viele jahre ungestört rauchen dort ist
es mittlerweile auch völlig verboten und
europa ist von einer einheitlichen
umsetzung dieser aus gesundheitlicher
sicht sehr wichtigen richtlinie weit
entfernt
ihr seht also die eu ist kein
bundesstaat
aber sie ist auch kein staatenbund sie
ist irgendwas dazwischen eine kategorie
für sich jetzt fragt ihr euch vielleicht
funktioniert dieses zwischending modell
tatsächlich auf längere sicht oder
müssen wir die idee der vereinigten
staaten und europa voranbringen
was läuft in der europäischen union
falsch wir alle haben von den vielen
vielen fehlern gehört die im
europäischen einigungsprozess gemacht
wurden
aber die wahrheit ist viele dieser
mängel hätten auf ganz individuelle
weise auch gut in den einzelnen
mitgliedstaaten auftreten können nimmt
zum beispiel die flüchtlingskrise fakt
ist dass brüssel nicht in der lage war
eine gemeinschaftliche linie durch und
umzusetzen welche eine geeignete
asylpolitik für die aus den mittleren
osten und nordafrika flüchtenden
menschen auf den weg gebracht hätte
aber lügen wir uns hier nicht selbst in
die tasche ebenso versagte jedes
einzelne land für sich die spanische
regierung tat was sie nur konnte um
flüchtlinge zurückweisen zu können
während die stadtverwaltung von madrid
also der hauptstadt spaniens mit aller
kraft genau das gegenteil dass man rede
rathaus plant ein willkommenes projekt
um für flüchtlinge einen platz zum leben
zu schaffen
kurz gesagt wir können nicht erwarten
dass brüssel alle jene probleme löst
welche die nationalstaaten schon immer
hatten und noch nicht mal selbst der
lage sind für sich zu klären
in der politik sind solche dinge einfach
nicht möglich was wir damit aber nicht
sagen wollen ist dass die europäische
union perfekt sein
in der tat hat diese institution sehr
sehr viele hausgemachte probleme
[Musik]
stelle ich zum beispiel vor ihr seid
freiberufler in ungarn und arbeitet für
ein unternehmen in belgien
wenn ihr euren kunden jetzt eine
rechnung schreibt müsst ihr diese mit
mehrwert schnell ausstellen nach den eu
rechtsvorschriften nicht weil es sich um
einen innergemeinschaftlichen dieses
vertrag handelt
aber jedes land hat seine eigenen
steuergesetze die in vielen fällen
leider den eu regeln widersprechen all
diese probleme könnten gelöst werden
wenn eine gemeinsame basis für die
steuergesetzgebung existieren würde
vieler länder wollen einfach ihre
eigenständigkeit gerade in dieser
schlüsselfrage nicht verlieren und
niemand wagt es hier den ersten schritt
zu gehen denn je macht über die steuern
bis die macht über das geld des staates
und die kein politiker so mir nichts dir
nichts hergeben und so ist es
unglaublich schwierig in wichtigen
entscheidungen voranzukommen also was
könnte die lösung dieses problems sein
[Musik]
ein klub mit unterschiedlichen arten von
mitgliedschaften verfassungen sind eine
praktische sache sie ermöglichen es
politikern und gesetzgebern sich zu
orientieren und bescheid zu wissen was
sie tun können und was sie besser lassen
sollten
sie sind eine mindest vereinbarung auf
diese weise weiß einer regierung was sie
als gesetz durchsetzen kann und was
nicht
es handelt sich um ein system das sich
im laufe der zeit bewährt und als
effektiv erwiesen
wo liegt also das problem nun alle
versuche eine europäische verfassung zu
verabschieden sind gescheitert im jahr
2005 hatten sowohl frankreich als auch
die niederlande referenten in denen sie
den vorschlag für eine europäische magna
charta ablenken jahre darauf trafen im
größten die der politiker zusammen um
eine neue version dieser verfassung zu
schreiben den sogenannten lissabonner
vertrag
dies war eine mildere version der zuvor
entworfenen und eben den referenten
verbraucht einfach sein
aber alles das halt nichts die
integrationsprobleme bestanden weiter
denn jedes land hat seine eigenen
interessen und eigenheiten und es ist
verdammt schwer sie alle auf die gleiche
seite zu bekommen
warum also sollte man diese unterschiede
nicht anerkennen
genau aus diesem grunde legte die
europäische kommission das europäische
weißbuch auf in diesem werden fünf
mögliche szenarien für eine reform der
eu vorgestellt
jedes dieser szenarien würde jedem staat
ein anderes integrations niveau
ermöglicht einen anderen vorschlag
entwarf die britische wirtschaftszeitung
die economist anfang 2017
sie skizzierte eine europäische union
mit verschiedenen arten von
mitgliedschaften auf der einen seite
wären die premium-mitglieder diejenigen
die eine gemeinsame währung teilen sowie
eine gemeinsame steuer- und außenpolitik
betreiben
[Musik]
auf der anderen seite gebe es die silber
mitgliedschaft welche einen gemeinsamen
markt und die arbeitnehmer freizügigkeit
mit sich bringen würde
in der dritten kategorie nennen wir sie
mal bronze mitgliedschaft wird nur der
zugang zum gemeinsamen markt ermöglicht
und mehr nicht
auf diese weise wäre es viel einfacher
jedes land davon zu überzeugen für eine
gemeinsame europäische verfassung zu
stellen
unterdessen hat die idee der vereinigten
staaten von europa viele anhänger
verloren
die idee eines europa der
unterschiedlichen mitgliedschaften
geschwindigkeiten und integrations
gerade genießt derzeit viel mehr
unterstützung
und jetzt kommt die frage an euch denkt
ihr diese mischung aus bundesstaat
staatenbund mit verschiedenen mitglieds
kategorien kann tatsächlich hinzunehmen
oder sollten wir uns weiterhin zu einem
lupenreinen bundesstaat einsätzen in dem
für alle die gleichen regeln gelten
lasst uns wissen was ihr darüber denkt
dafür gibt es den super komfortablen
kommentarbereich unter diesem video
vergesst bitte auch nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren wir veröffentlichen jede
woche brandneue videos also klickt auf
den abo button und du wirst keinen
beitrag verpassen wenn dir dieses video
gefallen hat gibt uns einen like daumen
und die immer bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]